i wanted to show them something that
wasn't an illusion
something that was real
something that we can
see and touch
creation
is an act of sheer will
life
will find a way
we can't keep her here forever
they find her we're never gonna see her
again we gotta protect her that's our
job
[Music]
humans and dinosaurs can't coexist
[Music]
we created an ecological disaster
ali settler
alan grant
you didn't come out all this way just to
catch up now did you
you coming or what
[Music]
we're racing toward the extinction of
our species
we not only lack dominion over nature
we're subordinate to it
[Music]
come back i always come back
that's another plane right
not exactly
don't move
bigger why do they always have to go
bigger
[Music]
every night
i dreamed the same dream
then
the nightmare begins
i did what i had to do
[Music]
to protect our world
you cannot control everything strange
you opened the doorway between
we don't know who or what will walk
through it
[Music]
wanda
what do you know about the multiverse
this had his theories
he believed it was dangerous
he was right
i'm sorry stephen
your desecration of reality
will not go unpunished
[Music]
we should tell him the truth
[Music]
things just got out of hand
[Music]
you break the rules look out
and become a hero
i do it i become the enemy
that doesn't seem fair
[Music]
did you know the very first assembly of
photographs to create a motion picture
was a two second clip of a black man on
a horse
and that man is my
great great grandfather great there's
another great grandfather
[Music]
but that's why back at the haywood ranch
as the only black owned horse trainers
in hollywood we like to say since the
moment pitches could move
yeah skin of the game
[Music]
my
it's a bad miracle
[Applause]
they got word for that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
who are you under there
what are you hiding
my son dreamt of a better world that's
why he saved me
you can go to any timeline and the
universe
might fight to save this one
what could be greater than a king
a hero
i just got goosebumps
if we don't stand up no one will
[Music]
come with us
it's a glorious world out there
waiting for you
are you in
where
are my manners sonic meet knuckles
so nice when diabolical evil lives up to
the height
[Music]
it turns out that we are both pretty big
sports fans tom boston sports are a way
of life tottenham fans can also be just
as intense well do the fans go shirtless
and freezing weather yes it's england do
they shout horrible things at their
rivals yes england did losses result in
grown men crying yes it's england i was
just crying yesterday i guess we're not
so different after all i've been
dreaming about this one 5 billion easy i
assume we're 50 50 right
we get 10 that's me being generous wow
uncharted exclusively in movie theaters
[Applause]
my wife needs this surgery
we're not the bad guys
we're just the guys trying to get home
i gotta get back to my life with my son
no matter what
i'm gonna get you back home little
brother
ambulance i'm gonna get everybody home
haven't you ever wondered
what else is out there
[Music]
there's wonders in this world
beyond our
[Music]
i can wandering it
i can't tell the difference
between my waking life
and dreams
it must be very difficult
the voice
this chaos
embrace it
[Music]